BRIAN DORSEY: Hello, everybody.
My name is Brian.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I'm Laurence.
BRIAN DORSEY: And we are
both from Developer Relations
on the Google Cloud
Platform, and we're
going to try an
experiment today.
So tell us more about it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, we'd like
to start just really having
a good, open conversation
with you developers, talk with
you about Google Cloud Platform
and about Cloud as a whole.
Obviously it's a little
too late for this video
to answer any of your questions.
But for future videos,
if you've any questions,
just put them in
the comments section
down here, like under
the video window,
not on the floor of this studio.
And we'd love to answer them.
And if we can't answer them--
I mean, between Brian and I,
we should be able to
answer most of them.
Mostly Brian answering, not me.
BRIAN DORSEY: It's a given we
won't know all the answers,
but--
LAURENCE MORONEY: If we don't,
we know the people that do,
and we'd love to bring it out
there and answer them for you.
BRIAN DORSEY: Fantastic.
So, yeah.
So, questions,
conversation topics,
like things you'd like to
hear about Cloud platform,
or anything goes.
Give us a shot.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Speaking of go?
BRIAN DORSEY: Go.
Anything goes.
So for today, I think we'll
try little, few questions here
between us, to get things going.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Totally unrehearsed.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Completely unrehearsed.
So you will see
flubs here and there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
we've seen a few already.
BRIAN DORSEY: So, Laurence,
what is Cloud to you?
How would your
previous experiences
developing software
and designing software
have changed if you
had Cloud as an option.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I guess I'm
quite experienced in designing
software, and developing
it a little bit.
And experienced
probably to the length
that it made me
a little cynical.
So forgive me if it
comes across as that,
but I think Cloud for me is
like, it's one of those terms
that we, as an industry--
and I don't mean
any particular company, but
just we as an industry-- haven't
done a great job in the past of
really articulating what it is
and what it means.
And I guess I could give
one example that-- it's
a funny little story
if you'll indulge me.
I used to be an architect on
a financial services platform.
And we built products
for Wall Street.
for financial analysts
on Wall Street.
And generally the way that
you'd build the product
is that an architect
would come in.
The architect talks to
the business people,
gathers the business
requirements,
takes a look at
the infrastructure
that we have in place
and joins the dots.
So for example,
it might be, we'd
build a product
that is providing
some financial analytics.
And so we have a
feed of fundamentals.
And we have a speed of data.
And we have a feed of history.
BRIAN DORSEY: At this point,
is it all lines and boxes?
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
all lines and boxes.
Exactly.
BRIAN DORSEY: Not software yet.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Not software yet.
It's lines and boxes
and Visio diagrams.
And cylinders.
Don't forget the cylinders.
BRIAN DORSEY: Cylinders
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Databases are cylinders.
They're not boxes.
So we'd draw all
these things up.
And before we'd get
developers involved,
we'd draw all this up.
And then we'd generally have
a big fluffy cloud, right?
So we have all our
lines and boxes
of our feeds and our databases,
and a big fluffy cloud.
And then a PC connected to it, a
mobile device connecting to it,
like a terminal connecting--
BRIAN DORSEY: So that's like the
internet and everything, or--
LAURENCE MORONEY: That was like
everything hidden behind it.
And I'm sure if you open Visio,
or other drafting tools today,
there's always an icon for
a big fluffy cloud, right?
And that was the cloud.
And I can remember,
for me the next step
is, once I've designed
this and I've figured out
all these feeds and where
I'm getting all this data,
I would bring the Ops people in.
And I remember
specifically, the best Ops
guy I've ever worked with--
I can't remember his name.
I remember it was
Scott something.
It's not Scott Guthrie.
And I remember it
was Scott something.
And I remember having
this conversation with him
and presenting the thing to him.
And he looked
through, and I thought
I'd done a fabulous
job of pitching
my architecture to him.
And his job would be
then to think about
how many servers do
we have running this?
How do we secure that?
How do we make sure the servers
are patched, managed, powered.
Yadda yadda yadda.
All this kind of stuff.
And I remember doing this
fabulous presentation
that I'd prepared for
weeks, and giving it
to this guy to get him on board.
And he said four words to me.
And these are words that I can
share on video, don't worry.
So what you think
the four words were?
BRIAN DORSEY: Um, "I love it?"
No, that's three words.
LAURENCE MORONEY: His four
words were, "There is no cloud."
BRIAN DORSEY: Wait.
OK.
This is 10 years ago?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, about that.
About that.
BRIAN DORSEY: So where was
he coming from with that?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Where
he was coming from--
and he was exactly
right-- was because,
if you think about the
complexity of running
an application like this, OK?
Security.
And the manageability.
Like I say, virus scanning.
Even the number of servers that
you need to run this thing.
We would actually do
a calculation that
would look at our
traffic and then would
say this one's going to be
a Java application running
on a Weblogic app server.
And we'd say, OK, we looked
at our traffic that we'd have.
We'd looked at the
number of users.
We'd figure out how
many-- based on the CPU,
based on the network
connectivity--
BRIAN DORSEY: So he's thinking
just straight logistics.
Like how do you get the
hardware you need to do that?
What networking
infrastructure do need?
How do the switches work?
Load balancing.
How much storage do we need?
You can't just handwave
that away and draw--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hide
it behind a fluffy cloud.
BRIAN DORSEY: Gotcha.
Well, how does that change now?
That's not really what
we think of as Cloud now,
but it kind of is.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
that's the main thing.
And that's the magic,
the perceived magic
that I as an architect would
do is draw a fluffy cloud
and hide away all
the complexity.
BRIAN DORSEY: It all just works?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
and it all just works.
That is a reality now.
It's no longer a
perceived magic.
Right?
Because we work with the
Google Cloud Platform.
And I'm going to go
do my Superman thing,
go-- You know, we work with
the Google Cloud Platform now.
And so the nice
thing about that is
if we build applications that
run, for example on App Engine.
And it was funny
that I was talking
about Java and Weblogic.
And App Engine supports Java,
which makes me very happy.
And then all of
those complexities
of scaling up when you
need it, and scaling down
when you don't need it, and
only paying for what you use.
BRIAN DORSEY: So
now that's all real.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's all real.
Because in his-- to go
back to my friend who said,
"There is no cloud," he would
look at the amount of traffic
that we need.
We'll calculate the
number of servers
that we'd need for that.
And then we had an algorithm
based on a bathtub curve type
thing and-- what
do you call that?
A binary curve.
And I think we calculated the
average number of servers,
and we multiplied
that by 2 root 2.
And that would give us the 95
percent estimate for traffic.
And so we might need
10 servers for traffic,
but would end up
with 28 servers.
And for the times from
outside of nine to five,
those 28 servers are still
sitting there and not
being used.
And average times, we're using
10, and 18 of them were unused.
And for the sake
of peak time, we
might use 23, 24, 25 of them.
But now with Cloud,
now we can talk
about that kind of fluffy
thing and all of that magic
is going on for us.
BRIAN DORSEY: It really exists.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it
really, really exists.
I'd love to have
Scott on a future show
and ask him, "Is
there a cloud now?"
BRIAN DORSEY: Let's find him.
OK.
So I had kind of a
related experience.
I spent many years working on
a system for distributing files
around many locations
so that they were always
available from
all of these sites
that the organization worked at.
And we were trying to
create the illusion
that all of these files
were available everywhere.
And realistically,
you would keep
a hot set of files,
or recent things,
or some subset of what
you could actually
afford to keep
there at some sites.
And maybe other sites
would have everything.
And you have too many
copies of everything,
really because you
don't need them all.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Asset
management's a difficult
problem.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
And you look at things like
Google Cloud Storage, which
is blob storage
service in the Cloud.
And it essentially is that
entire system that we built,
just ready to use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: As a service.
BRIAN DORSEY: As a service.
The entire product doesn't even
need to be built in that way.
So that would save a
huge amount of time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you
could have really focused
on building out the
user experience.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Instead of the plumbing
and the infrastructure.
BRIAN DORSEY: And what we
wanted to build on top of that.
Because this was all just
a necessary foundation
to get to what we
were trying to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: There are
only so many hours in the day.
And so if you're spending all
that time and all those cycles
building that planning,
think about the things
that you're not building.
BRIAN DORSEY: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And particularly
nowadays, I feel
folks have much more
of a demand for a rich
user experience than they
used to have.
The things that were
acceptable 10 years ago
are completely
unacceptable today,
because now you have
the luxury of being
able to hide behind
that big fluffy cloud
with its own storage.
And now you can focus on
building a better user
experience and such
a thing like that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Totally.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So do
you have a feature of Cloud
that kind of gets you excited?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah!
There's a bunch of things,
like so many things about Cloud
that gets me really excited.
I mean, the big picture,
like the whole Cloud
space is super
exciting right now.
I think we've gotten to the
point where you can create
a model of the hardware
we used to have
to run all these things.
So you've got your servers,
and you've got your networks,
and switches, and
everything that you
used to have to go to a
data center and do by hand,
there's an API for.
And that is super useful,
incredibly exciting,
and allows a layer--
a level of automation
that just wasn't
possible before.
And there's peaks and slopes.
But I don't think we're
done there, right?
This is the next
step of figuring out,
OK now that these things
that used to be physical
are abstract concepts, are
they the right abstractions
we want for building
software in the future?
And I think we can
do better, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, absolutely.
BRIAN DORSEY: And so there's
things that are really exciting
right now.
So App Engine's really
interesting in that space.
I think Docker is
super exciting.
There's a bunch of
stuff going on there.
So Cloud as a whole,
super exciting.
I think in Compute
Engine terms, we've
got a load balancer
that's basically
Google's datacenter-level
load balancing
available as a feature
for you to use.
We've got Block Storage,
where it's super consistent,
and that's like its primary
design goal is consistency.
Great for running databases
on, things like that.
But I think if I
wanted to just--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Pick one.
BRIAN DORSEY: Pick one?
BRIAN DORSEY: I'm
actually going to pick--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I put
a gopher to your head
and ask you to pick one.
BRIAN DORSEY: Only one.
OK.
I think I would have to pick
Notifications in Cloud Storage.
Cloud Storage is this
blobstore in the sky.
You can push files to it,
and you can get them back
from anywhere in the world.
And it has, essentially,
subscription notifications.
You can say, at
this HTTP endpoint,
that's my application.
I want you to send the metadata
for every single change that
happens to this bucket.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice
BRIAN DORSEY: So you
can build workflow.
And you can build
deep integration
between Cloud Storage
and any application,
whether that's running
on Google Cloud or not.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So going back to
your video scenario.
So if you're
building a video app
and you've got people all over
the world shooting footage
for a movie or
something like that,
and then somebody
puts some new footage,
everybody's going
to be notified.
BRIAN DORSEY: So you can get
notifications to tell people
about it.
You could kick off a
transcoding process.
You can just deeply integrate
it within your whole app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Cool.
BRIAN DORSEY: Anything
you need to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
there's an API for that?
BRIAN DORSEY: There's
an API for that.
There's an API for everything.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They used to
say, "There's an app for that."
Now we say, "There's
an API for that."
BRIAN DORSEY: There's
an API for that.
So if you had to pick
one, what's your--
LAURENCE MORONEY: If I
put the gopher to my head?
Oh, there's so many.
I think one, for
me, that actually--
the very first thing.
You know what they say
about first love is
the one you remember.
So the first love for
me with the Google Cloud
was actually Java.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
I know it's a surprise.
BRIAN DORSEY: Coming from
Python background, I'm like--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Over
in Python background.
I've got some great stuff to
say about Python, but maybe
for a future video.
But I think it's because I
came from a Java background.
And I worked for
Microsoft for many years
and moved more into
the ASP.NET background.
But really, one of the
things that disappointed me
about Java years ago
was how hard it was,
and how expensive it was, for
you to put Java stuff publicly.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Like if you had an App
Server, like for a J2EE thing,
those things cost in the
10s of thousands of dollars.
And--
BRIAN DORSEY: So compared
to your PHP app, or--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Python app, you know,
where you can $2 a month, for a
server, and that kind of thing.
And it was like, I'd
really like to be
able to showcase some Java work.
But I couldn't!
OK?
Short of putting an app
server, like a Tomcat,
or something that, on a
machine under my desk,
and opening port
80 on my router--
BRIAN DORSEY: So you're
a good Java programmer
and you've made some
awesome thing in Java,
and you want to show it off.
What do you do?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
applying for a job.
It's a Java job.
And I want to show
some Java stuff.
Can't do it.
But then, what comes
along, but App Engine?
And I know I'm holding
the gopher now,
so he'd probably feel
a bit disappointed
I'm talking about a
different language.
And App Engine.
And now I can use Eclipse.
And I can put a simple
plug-in into Eclipse,
and I can start
writing code in Java.
And I can deploy
it to App Engine.
And I'm not even
paying a monthly fee.
I'm paying based on usage.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
So this is a case where it
scales down really well,
in addition to scaling up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
And actually, I haven't been
working at Google that long.
And as part of my
interview process,
I've had this algorithm that
I've been working on for years,
where it's like I do predictive
analysis of the stock market.
So take a look at the
history of a stock price,
and then take a guess from
there what it's going be at.
And I thought, OK, here's
a great example for me to--
and I had originally
written this in Java.
And I moved it to C Sharp.
And I dusted off my old
Java and put into AppSpot.
AppSpot is where you
host AppEngine apps.
And so for my actual interview,
my first interview here
at Google, I showed them.
And it was on that particular
day, it was really interesting.
Because it was predicting
that Google would spike,
and it would go up.
And I told my interviewers,
because you're talking to me.
BRIAN DORSEY: How'd it turn out?
Did it--
LAURENCE MORONEY: They hired me.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
Good to go.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Well, we saw that we
went over $1,000 soon
afterwards, right?
So.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
Fantastic.
Thank you very much
for this time together.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
thank you, viewers.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
Thanks for watching
all the way to the end.
So are you interested in
seeing more stuff like this?
Yes or no.
Like, other topics
you'd like to hear.
Hit up the comments and we'll
be in touch and do more.
Talk to you soon.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
BRIAN DORSEY: Bye.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All righty.
BRIAN DORSEY: OKey-doke.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we're
recording now, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: We are
absolutely recording now.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Out-takes have begun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes they have.
We haven't even begun
the in-takes yet.
BRIAN DORSEY:
Respect The gopher.
No--
LAURENCE MORONEY: We have
to respect the gopher.
That's true.
BRIAN DORSEY: No
throwing the gopher.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Maybe we could even
defer to him for some questions.
BRIAN DORSEY: If I get stuck,
you know who to talk to.